una forma de crear un esther es utilizar
una reacción de esterificación de fisher
si empiezas con un ácido carboxílicos y
añades un alcohol y una fuente de
protones formará un este y también harás
agua en este proceso
es importante saber que el oxígeno y el
grupo r prima viene de tu alcohol y
veremos eso en el mecanismo también esta
reacción está en equilibrio por lo que
si quieres hacer más de tu producto
esther tienes que mover el equilibrio a
la derecha y hay un par de maneras de
hacer eso algo que puedes hacer es
disminuir la concentración de agua lo
que mandaría a tu equilibrio a la
derecha y haría más de tu esther también
podrías hacer algo como aumentar la
concentración de alcohol y eso mandaría
al equilibrio a la derecha también
veamos el mecanismo para formar estrés
empezamos con nuestro ácidos
carboxílicos y vamos a protón ar el
oxígeno cierto entonces un par libre de
electrones en el oxígeno puede tomar un
protón dejando a estos electrones atrás
y ahora podemos mostrar que hemos protón
ado el oxígeno aquí por lo que obtiene
una carga formal de más 1
la proto nación de tu carbón y lo activa
tu carbón y lo y hacia tu carbono más
electro físico este carbono ahora es más
electro físico vivimos eso en algunos de
los vídeos anteriores y si nuestro
carbono es más electro físico tiene
sentido que nuestro siguiente paso sea
un ataque núcleo físico entonces una
molécula de alcohol viene y puedes
pensar en un par libre de electrones en
el oxígeno atacando este carbono de aquí
empujando a estos electrones hacia tu
oxígeno
continuamos mostrando el resultado de
nuestro ataque en núcleo físico ahora
tenemos un oxígeno aquí arriba tenía un
par libre y ahora tiene dos pares libres
está enlazado a un hidrógeno y luego
aquí a la derecha está el enlace que
acabamos de formar el enlace entre
carbono y oxígeno mostremos esos
electrones en magenta este par libre en
el oxígeno forma el enlace entre carbono
y oxígeno
ahí está el este oxígeno también hay un
hidrógeno
aún hay un grupo r prima y un par libre
de electrones dándole a este oxígeno una
carga formal de más 1
y aún hay un bache unido a nuestro
carbono así
el siguiente paso es deshacerse de esta
carga formal de +1 en el oxígeno viene
otra molécula de alcohol
y esta vez actúa como una base en el
paso anterior el alcohol actuó como
núcleo filo en este paso actuara como
una base tomará este protón y dejará a
estos electrones atrás en el oxígeno
continuamos haciendo más espacio aquí
abajo vamos a despertar continuamos
mostrando lo que haremos tenemos a
nuestro carbono enlazado a este oxígeno
de arriba y dos pares libres de
electrones en él un hidrógeno un grupo r
unido a la izquierda dibujaré este
oxígeno aquí abajo con dos pares libres
de electrones para que pueda mostrar el
siguiente paso
y luego este oxígeno de aquí ahora tiene
dos pares libres de electrones y aún
está unido a nuestro grupo r prima así
que mostremos esos electrones los
electrones en azul aquí se mueven al
oxígeno
y ese es un paso debes protón acción el
siguiente paso es protón ar el h de
abajo así que hagamos incluso más
espacio para mostrar eso vamos a mostrar
a este h de aquí abajo siendo des protón
a 2
así que dibujaré una fuente de protones
aquí abajo nuestro alcohol protón ado
más una carga formal de más 1 en nuestro
oxígeno nuestra r prima por aquí
entonces un par libre en este oxígeno
puede tomar un protón dejando a estos
electrones atrás
y tenemos un paso de protón acción la
razón por la cual esta protón acción es
favorecida es porque esto creará un
excelente grupo saliente sin esto más
detenimiento operas el agua ahí como
nuestro grupo saliente continuamos
mostrando eso ahora ese oxígeno de aquí
abajo ha sido protón ado por lo que
tiene una carga formal de más 1 este
oxígeno
así que mostremos esos electrones estos
electrones justo aquí en este oxígeno
tomaron este protón formando este enlace
a este protón continuamos dibujando el
resto de lo que tenemos tenemos nuestro
oxígeno con dos pares libres de
electrones y un grupo r prima así
en el siguiente paso apenas formamos
agua como nuestro grupo saliente aquí
si puedes verlo si estos electrones se
mueven al oxígeno puedes ver que eso es
agua entonces cuando estos electrones
libres en el oxígeno de arriba se mueven
a acá para formar el doble enlace ahí es
cuando estos electrones aquí en azul se
moverán al oxígeno y el agua es un
excelente grupo saliente
dibujemos lo que tenemos ahora
nuevamente todo está en equilibrio vamos
a formar nuevamente nuestro enlace doble
y este oxígeno de arriba ahora tiene una
carga formal de más 1 así que mostremos
esos electrones hagamos los rojos estos
electrones en rojo se volverán a mover
acá para formar nuevamente nuestro doble
enlace este carbono aún está unido a un
grupo r en el lado izquierdo este
carbono está unido a un oxígeno
el grupo r prima está por aquí el
oxígeno tiene dos pares libres de
electrones
y acabamos de perder agua así que déjame
dibujar el agua aquí abajo
perdimos h2o en este paso
y casi tenemos nuestro producto final
porque todo lo que tenemos que hacer es
des protón ar por aquí y formamos
nuestro esther podemos mostrar otra
molécula de alcohol acercándose una r
prima dos pares libres de electrones
tomando este protón de aquí dejando a
estos electrones atrás en nuestro
oxígeno continuamos dibujando la
estructura final de nuestro esther
tenemos r la hace doblemente enlazada
con la o con dos pares libres de
electrones así que demostremos a estos
electrones de aquí moviéndose a nuestro
oxígeno así y luego nuestro carbono aún
está enlazado a este oxígeno y tenemos
nuestro grupo r prima entonces nuestro
resultado final es formar nuestro esther
y agua bien ese es un mecanismo un poco
largo ahora veamos algunas reacciones
para formar esther es a partir de la
esterificación de fisher empecemos con
esta molécula aquí a la izquierda
esto es ácido salicílico
y añadimos metanol y usamos ácido
sulfúrico como nuestra fuente de
protones vamos a formar un esther y esta
es una práctica famosa que siempre se
hace en laboratorios de química orgánica
en la universidad pensamos en el
mecanismo
recuerda recuerda que este oxígeno en
nuestro alcohol y en este caso este
metal van a sumarse es cierto así que
perderemos este h en nuestro ácidos
carboxílicos y vamos a poner este
oxígeno y este grupo metido reemplazando
lo continuamos dibujando el producto
tendríamos nuestro anillo de benceno
aquí
tendríamos nuestro carbono doblemente
unido a un oxígeno y tendríamos el
oxígeno del alcohol y luego nuestro
grupo metilo así
y aún tenemos nuestro aquí la razón por
la cual esta es una práctica clásica de
laboratorio en la universidad es porque
esto es de luthería tiene un color
increíble siempre es muy divertido hacer
esto en un laboratorio universitario
porque el laboratorio huele muy bien
cuando acabas está en la síntesis de la
galería veamos otra esterificación de
fisher esta es un poco diferente
esta es una esterificación intra
molecular de fisher si vemos nuestra
molécula inicial en la izquierda esta
vez tenemos nuestro ácidos carboxílicos
y nuestro alcohol en la misma molécula y
tenemos todos estos enlaces simples por
aquí los cuales sabemos podemos tener
una rotación libre si dibujamos la
molécula en una conformación distinta
continuamos haciendo
tenemos nuestro ácidos carboxílicos aquí
arriba y contemos cuántos carbonos
tenemos déjame utilizar rojo para esto
tenemos uno tenemos el carbono 12
4 y 5 tenemos 5 carbonos continuamos
dibujando los aquí aquí está el carbono
1 2
y 5
y luego tenemos nuestro h así que déjame
continuar enumerando esos carbonos
ese es el carbono 1 el carbono 2 el
carbono 3 el carbono 4 y el carbono 5 y
entonces en una conformación distinta
podríamos pensar en este oxígeno
atacando este carbón y lo
sabemos sabemos que vamos a perder
sabemos que vamos a perder a este h
sabemos que vamos a perder este
hidrógeno podemos juntar a esos dos y
pensar en nuestro producto final cierto
vamos a formar un esther pero un esther
distinto a los que hemos visto antes
tenemos nuestro carbón y lo aquí y luego
tenemos este oxígeno este oxígeno es
ahora miembro de nuestro anillo y vino
de este oxígeno podemos ver nuestros 5
carbonos 1 2 3
45 podemos pensar en perder agua aquí y
nuestro producto es llamado la actora
esta es la que
no es un esther en un anillo aquí
tenemos un anillo de seis miembros donde
el oxígeno es uno de los miembros del
anillo bien podemos decir que formar la
actora es una reacción y trã molecular
de fisión bastante interesante